you started this company when
uh in late 2012 and you worked on it
for a couple of years and then
you were gonna quit because it wasn't
working is this true
uh so actually the uh this last
attempt was the fourth attempt at uh
having it
starting the company so the first
attempt was in 2004
i believe i'm getting the the timing
right then 2006 then 2007
and then again the last time in 2012 all
the same corporate entity or they were
just projects all different entities
different co-founders first two were
just by myself second one was uh
different co-founders one of whom is
actually working on what flow now
uh this last time hopefully last time
yeah last and final time
uh was started in late 2012 and the
like that's around the time where um so
same co-founders
now one of them is my brother one of
them as a
coworker at intuit that's when i almost
went bankrupt and the company went
bankrupt
because we we first wanted to just
bootstrap we wanted to do
a kickstarter campaign and i only had
like three months of family runway to
like invest in the company
it ended up so it kind of promised my
wife like oh we're gonna get funding
within no problem
yeah of course i mean not not a big deal
leave this you know well-paying job and
i just do the startup thing uh but then
we ended up going uh more than 12 months
without funding oh wow so that's where
and my on fumes
on fumes and my daughter ended up having
uh really like critical
uh surgery and it was like catastrophic
health insurance and
so we almost uh kind of fizzled out
about six months after founding
um this was like pre-y combinator uh
pre-funding and everything we were
like about ready to give up go back to
our jobs i'm falling in love with you
right now
i'm literally like as an investor and a
founder it's just like
i always tell people the reason
companies fail is not because they run
out of money
because the founder quits you worked
with no salary
and you convinced your team and your
co-founders to work without a salary
yep for six months 12 months for 12
months
uh actually 12 months total the last
three months we're
working on uh minimum wage because yc
told us
hey you have to pay yourselves uh if if
one of the founders
quits and didn't get paid then there's
like a yeah liability exactly because
you don't own the ip assignment
exactly intellectual so that has to be
like consideration there has to be
something in order for you to own that
okay
yeah and it wasn't until august 2013 uh
in september 2013 when we did our seed
round that we were able to actually pay
ourselves
and you posted this story on hacker news
i guess back in 2013.
that's the didn't post the full story
didn't uh
but we did uh around the beginning of
2013 that's when we were like
i was almost bankrupt uh you know we're
considering
moving back and going uh back to our
jobs uh that's when we said look we have
to like
give ourselves a deadline a month and
post something on hacker news we're not
going to be able to build a full product
uh just post an idea of it and then see
if it sticks
and it in it stuck like the it was
number one on hacker news for the whole
day uh
for those who don't know hacker news is
like reddit but
for founders and developers started by y
combinator you can go to
news.ycombinator.com
and i love this tweet my webflow journey
2004 idea 2005 first try failed 2006
married
2007 second try failed 2008 third try
failed
2009 kid number one 2010 day job 2011
kid 2. 2012 fourth try yc says no
2013 yc says yes funded get 100k in the
bank
2014 hard work begins wow you are a real
jedi samurai
it didn't feel like it at the time oh of
course it doesn't yeah
go watch the seven samurai when they're
in the mud go watch
you know luke skywalker lose a hand i
mean this is serious business
entrepreneurship and we live in a time
of entitlement
unlimited vacation work from home free
food all kinds of nonsense
you worked with no salary for a year
trudging through the mud what kept you
at it in those moments what is it about
you and your
team that you just would not give up
two things uh one of them blind optimism
like in the moment it just felt like oh
it's right around the corner this is
gonna work out like it didn't
to my wife it didn't feel that way yeah
uh yeah but
god bless the and spouse's yeah the the
amount of commitment
um that's required is just nuts to think
about
um especially not seeing like everything
like all the all the potential promise
like the vision
i had in my head for you know for this
product for this movement etc
um so that that's part of it sort of
like blinds you to reality
uh and maybe has you uh make like pretty
dumb financial decisions like i
pulled out almost all of my money from
401k which is like a huge penalty when
you do it
yeah you pay tax which you know i
wouldn't advise friends to do
but you know in the moment it's like all
right it's just like another place to
get money
uh okay to pay the bills et cetera um
and this is with the kid
there's two kids with two kids at the
time uh they were one and three when we
first yeah that's quite a discussion
with your
spouse yeah yeah i'm gonna take fifty
thousand dollars out of a 401k
right exactly plowed into my third swing
at bat
fourth swing at bat and it wasn't just
that we had to sell
we had to sell two cars and switch them
to because we had
you know cars that we had paid for
before we uh sold both cars and switched
to leases
so that way it's like you get some cash
in the bank to pay for rent and then you
you have like you know a couple hundred
dollars a month or whatever
and i think we racked up close to 60k in
credit card debt you know those like uh
personal uh yeah exactly those uh you
know two percent you'd sign yourself a
check for
and of course it's like i'm speaking
from a position of privilege the fact
that i had the credit
is awesome a lot of people don't have
that uh but it was still yeah you
weren't gonna happen for much longer
right razor's edge for sure yeah the
second part
i think is um you know what you
mentioned around like the impact of
like this this vision of what no code
can do this started in 2000 um
when i wrote my senior project on on
this idea because i was working at an
agency and i saw
what i was a intern that was translating
designs
into production so this was in san luis
obispo
i was going to cal poly and there was an
agency called web associates now
like they've been in st louis abysmal
what's it like
san luis obispo san luis obispo it's
amazing it's the central coast
yeah it's like i've never been there but
people rave about it i want to retire
there
it's amazing it's like the weather's
great it's the beach is right there
it's a college community right yeah it's
it's amazing
um why hasn't that blown up like because
you would think
that san francisco and la would become a
mega city at one point and everything in
between would connect them kind of like
in judge dredd but without the dystopian
kind of parts to it but you would think
like you know tokyo has expanded and
just keeps growing
why hasn't silicon valley grown down to
st
louis obispo or you know santa barbara
and los angeles connected
i think transportation infrastructure
won so you know tokyo is amazing
train coverage yeah uh here we don't
have the
the same and i think uh now with remote
but like more remote companies more
remote tools this is starting to happen
yeah